je crois que c'est jamais perdu si
jamais perdu dans le sens où il ya quand
même une deuxième mi temps à jouer et
qu'il faut aller jusqu'à la 95e minute
puisqu'il ya aussi les arrêts de jeu à
jouer on l'a vu dernièrement avec
l'équipe de france a été un bon exemple
cette semaine et puis il y à 48% en
absence d'abstentionnistes pardon sur ce
premier tour qu'on va aussi mobilisés
pour découvrir un petit peu cette
supercherie qu'on avait pu voir depuis
un grand match et fagots cette petite
sûrement cette petite surprise mais
enfin je pense
regardez aussi un peu le bon sens et
commencent à regarder un petit peu d'ici
l'été et prendre un petit peu de recul
par rapport à tout ça expliquait le
droit qu'on peut pas aussi s'attribuer
une étiquette qu'on n'a pas notamment
celle de la république en marche
l'affiché un petit peu partout et
tromper les gens avec cela moi je crois
qu'ils trouveront je me suis fait le jeu
je crois qu'en terme de avez vous vu ou
afin que je suis vous êtes mal placés
mais si vous donnez pas d'argent le
débat les jeunes gens ne veulent pas
d'accord que je crois aussi à un moment
donné dès votre projet politique je
crois aussi qu à un moment donné on va
être sur vraiment un duel gauche droite
gauche droite puisque le député sortant
est quand même bien le député du parti
socialiste et d'europe écologie les
verts parce qu'il faut aussi qu'ils
assument le bilan de françois hollande
qui d'ailleurs françois hollande n'a pas
pu se représenter durant pour ce
deuxième quinquennat potentiel donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi pouvoir que les
gens soient au courant de cette
machination